due to a doping scandal Russia is banned
from the 2020 Olympics and the 2022
World Cup yeah yeah Russia replied no
problem at least we can still
participate in America's 2020
presidential election that's what
they're best at actually they're good at
that today Elizabeth Warren released
documents from 1986 showing money she
made from her law practice yeah
then Buddha jej released documents from
1986 showing money he made from the
Tooth Fairy so it's very young yeah and
he's got a lot of big donors yes yeah
the miniseries Chernobyl got four Golden
Globe nominations yeah after hearing
this the victims of Chernobyl said
totally worth it
doctors in Serbia removed a testicle
from one identical twin and attached it
to the other yeah the only problem is
they were in there for a kidney
transplant
that was terrible
I can't believe that worked I should
have really did put given the punchline
even more push you know yeah the only
problem is they were in there for a
kidney transplant they were in there for
a kidney transplant I got a really zing
it next time yeah yeah gotta put more
mustard on these things that's what we
call it the biz